on Hong Kong's Northwestern Coast Tom
Chan Spends His Mornings trying to bring
back a chapter of the territory's past
we want to restore this abandoned oyster
Farm back to a more naturally looking
habitat so that it can provide the
ecological function as a normal oyster
Reef
next 700 years many of these traditional
Farms were abandoned when more modern
techniques were introduced now
conservationists are trying to restore
them to help save the reefs
Hong Kong once had thriving oyster reefs
but a number of factors including
Coastal Reclamation pollution and
over-exploitation have led to a decline
in Oyster populations over the past 150
years
scientists say restoring the Old Farms
is a fast and effective way to boost
oyster populations one of the the big
benefits with something like an
abandoned oyster Farm is that you've
already got oysters growing if you can
consolidate that structure bring it
together to form more of a reef-like
structure you've got a head start
researchers estimate about 80 percent of
oyster reefs around the world have been
removed or damaged Professor Russell
says restoring them is important to
revitalizing marine ecosystems they form
reefs they form big structures which
provide habitat for other organisms so
there's thousands of species which live
in and around oyster reefs oyster reefs
also help mitigate Coastal erosion and
help reduce toxic algae blooms
the researchers say restoring reefs and
sustainable harvesting can go together
because farmers can benefit from an
increase in the number of oysters
in Hong Kong's bustling Victoria Harbor
researchers are deploying a different
method putting oyster shells back in the
ocean to attract other marine life
so this is the oyster string that we put
into the ocean and 10 months before so
we have like a completely cured oyster
shells and then we draw them assemble
them and then put it into the ocean so
this oyster shell substrate for other
marine organisms to live on that
they say they want to teach people the
harbor belongs to everyone including its
oysters Jessica Washington altazira Hong
Kong